is there anyone here who does not
understand Swedish okay it was about 20
years ago when I built my first ice
musical instrument on top of a mountain
and I tightened the strings and I
plucked on the wires and I heard the
sound coming out from inside the
instrument and I was so excited by what
I heard that I put on my skis i keyed
all the way down to the village and I
told him what had happened to me and how
excited I was they pretty much thought I
was a kook well on that day I sort of
had a dream a vision of what could one
day become welcome to my dream
[Music]
[Music]
the ice instrument is it's made of
frozen water we're made of melted water
and that physical connection opens the
door for a spiritual connection and for
me when I listen to an ice instrument it
just makes me happy
[Music]
[Music]
it's one thing to build an ice
instrument it's another thing to
maintain it and use it throughout time
the ice is always sublimating away into
the atmosphere players get up next to
the instruments you got hot bodies next
to cold instruments and they're melting
and the audience walks in suddenly the
temperature rises because they're
breathing in that case the the strings
on the stringed instruments begin to get
softer and the tuning the pitch goes
down on stringed instruments on the pipe
instruments for instance the the Rolando
phone the the tubes in the xylophone and
so on those begin to go up so you've got
the orchestra going in two different
directions it took me quite a while
really to understand that that all of
the tuning and all is it just a complete
disaster was because of the temperature
fluctuation and that eventually led me
to realizing that I need to build my own
architecture that can ventilate the heat
from the audience away from the
orchestra and that's how we came to the
the basic design of the concert hall
that we have with the two domes which
accommodates for letting out the heat of
the audience and keeping the instruments
in the cool you know I think of magic
really the definition for me of magic is
unbelievable but happening and I think
that in the long run is that is the
kaboom possibility for ice music to
really affect the world the people in
the world in in this release of really
joy when your disbelief dissolves
thank you for the music for giving it to
me
[Music]
thank you for tonight
have a lovely evening
[Music]